this is a demo that really tests your
understanding of how light works what
we've got here is a cylinder full of
sugar water basically and a powerful
lamp shining white light through a
polarizing filter and there's also
another linearly polarizing filter on
the other end when we turn the lamp on
you see that the light gets separated
out into these diagonal colored bands
and if you rotate that first filter
those bands seem to walk down the tube
like a barber pole also take note of how
the light coming out the other end
through that second filter is no longer
white you might think okay it's whatever
color happens to be at the end of this
barber pole rainbow but that can't be
right because rotating the second filter
causes that color shining onto the wall
to change and I think what I found most
bizarre about the whole thing is why
those stripes are diagonal wouldn't you
expect the whole setup to be symmetric
from the top to the
[Music]
bottom